all men are created equal and they are
endowed with the rights to life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness not so fast
mr. Jefferson these words from the
Declaration of Independence and the
facts behind them are well known in June
of 1776 a little more than a year after
the war against England began with the
shots fired Lexington and Concord the
Continental Congress was meeting in
Philadelphia to discuss American
independence after long debates a
resolution of Independence was approved
on July 2nd 1776 America was free and
men like John Adams thought we would
celebrate that date forever but it was
two days later that the gentlemen in
Congress voted to adopt the declaration
of independence largely written by
Thomas Jefferson offering all the
reasons why the country should be free
more than 235 years later we celebrate
that day as America's birthday but there
are some pieces of the story you may not
know first of all Thomas Jefferson gets
the credit for writing the Declaration
but five men had been given the job to
come up with a document explaining why
America should be independent robert
Livingston Roger Sherman Benjamin
Franklin and John Adams were all named
first and it was Adams who suggested
that the young and little-known Thomas
Jefferson joined them because they
needed a man from the influential
Virginia delegation
and Adams thought Jefferson was a much
better writer than he was second though
Jefferson never used footnotes or
credited his sources some of his
memorable words and phrases were
borrowed from other writers and slightly
tweaked then Franklin Adams offered a
few suggestions but the most important
change came after the Declaration was
turned over to the full Congress for two
days of very unhappy Thomas Jefferson
sat and fumed while his words were
picked over in the end the Congress made
a few minor word changes and one big
deletion in the long list of charges
that Jefferson made against the king of
England the author of the Declaration
had included the idea that George the
3rd was responsible for the slave trade
and was preventing America from ending
slavery that was not only untrue but
Congress wanted no mention of slavery in
the nation's founding document the
reference was cut out before the
Declaration was approved and sent to the
printer but it leaves open the hard
question how could the men who were
about to sign a document celebrating
liberty and equality accept a system in
which some people owned others it is a
question that would eventually bring the
nation to Civil War and one we can still
ask today